good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Wednesday it is
hump day and episode nine nine nine nine
ninety nine plus it's hump day plus
we've got the straw guys and no you're
not confused you're not there was a
Switcheroo there was I have Thrice you
do Claudia has bright I do it's just
kind of the way that the chips fell and
we're always saying it's so important to
let the chips
ball where they may you know and this is
how they fell today and I think it's
always great to keep things fresh and
exciting and let the chips and let the
Stray Sands fall where they may you know
what chips is making me think lunch you
know what I hadn't thought I like it
hadn't entered my brain yet but now
you're gonna make me so hungry it's
never like not in my brain you know yeah
I just think we should start thinking
about what we want to have for lunch
today you know yeah like if you have any
ideas just like shout them out I will I
definitely I definitely will even though
you barely ate your lunch yesterday
barely it was gross it was gross but you
were also like not even hungry anymore
it was gross because we had mac and
cheese because we ate Harrisburg cheese
it was so good Harry is the best food oh
you wouldn't that's the only thing
empowers you yeah actually sometimes I
look at Harry's plate I'm like this is
child abuse like hummus like salmon
paste it's so organic and disgusting
like honestly Justice for Harry
but then it gets mac and cheese you know
once I saw he I opened the fridge and
then you know today I saw a big stock
pile of schnitzel of schnitzel some
breaded chicken you could have that for
lunch and I thought except for Harry is
that for me because there's no way Harry
could eat all of that before it goes bad
she did sulfur 40. it's a gallon bag
like a Ziploc bag full of [__] so there
must be 25 pieces in there yeah no it's
for you and Harry he'll have some
schnitzel for lunch and I think that's
our lunch plan I mean I did have
schnitzel for dinner
and it gave me diarrhea so I'll just
have to be cautious maybe your shinsel's
different maybe hopefully
is it gonna stop me no no let's talk
about today
we've got really like bottom of the
barrel crap so this story is actually
like in themselves aren't that bad but
like it took us a really long time to
Source them and you know if it were a
different day some of these stories
would not have made the cut they're crap
okay we're just setting expectations but
I find that those make the best episodes
and it's Wednesday so we have three
toasters in Dire Straits in need of our
help so it sounds like it's gonna be
like a pretty stunning episode a
wickedly talented one if I do say so
myself for 9.99 it better be you would
hope that we've learned the trade yeah
so it's 9.99 tomorrow that means is our
1 000th episode and I can't wait to you
know take care of myself on my one South
episode yeah we're really excited for
this really big milestone oh and
some of you guys might know this already
but we also did a patreon episode
yesterday it's video and audio podcast
episode if you're bored today and you
need more content patreon.com we're
doing one of our favorite installments
where we just
endlessly complain about the dumb
moronic [__] our spouses do we had a lot
of really good submissions from people
that were people submitted what their
husband does and then we all sort of
like commiserated really you know we
just all talk about our personal
experience every once in a while we're
like that's not that bad right or I have
no experience with that yeah that's rare
though and then I'm grateful yeah and
then so you're feeling on the one hand
like really bitter and then you also
come away feeling a little grateful it's
kind of therapeutic so if you're looking
for some sort of Outlet today I highly
recommend tuning into that episode on
our patreon yeah and there's video and
it's just really fun and then I actually
did three podcasts yesterday podcast
podcast
it'll be out next week I'm just gonna
tell you guys do it why not what was the
first one the toast the second one
patreon the third one good guys you guys
I'm a good girl and I'm going on good
guys I heard that the good guys were not
ready for the good girl that came in I
don't think they were ready for me I
think they were expecting a little girl
but then they got a good girl yeah I
don't think they were ready for me but
like Josh I were talking a lot about
like Parenthood and really the joys of
it because I feel like these days it's
like cool to like train your kids yeah
which I I feel like first and I said
this on the show I feel like for so long
you know you didn't talk about the like
hard Parts hard parts of paranoid you're
just like it's a joy yeah it's a
blessing
so it's nice that people like finally
are being honest yeah and you know like
things that were taboo are no longer
taboo but I do feel like the pendulum is
swung a little far where it's like we
kind of now only talk about the torture
yeah and we've forgotten a lot of the
joy The Joy well that sounds
beautiful it was really beautiful Jackie
that's beautiful and Josh was like
sharing tips and tricks for like dads
how they can really step up to the plate
and now that's nice and not be just like
these useless oafs that they are capable
of being no by the way and coming off
the heels of recording episode number
two for you which was you know how men
are useless that must have been really
refreshing to hear and I hope Ben
absorbs and I really understood why they
are the good guys they are the good guys
yeah no Ben is ready whenever you are
and I said of course you are you don't
have to do anything I literally at
dinner last night with the Shapiro's I
was like if Ben could carry these
children we would have six right like no
no no all of a sudden he wouldn't be so
ready right all of a sudden he wouldn't
be so ready I'm not feeling ready right
right [__] I'm like you carry you do
the breastfeeding like you get fat I
will support you I'm ready I'm ready I
take your time sweetheart yeah sure sure
yeah oh I feel better yeah yeah
shut up
um so that sounds like an exciting day I
read the dumbest book um it was called
scandalized if you just stop reading
dumb no because with my book club now
I'm like you get one smart a month right
so in between I'm like reading damn [__]
I'm fine and like if you're gonna meet
read the Midnight Library now which is
which is up next for me which is thought
provoking and I had to read scandalized
before yeah you need it in a moose a
moves in my Bouche and after I read like
a dumb smut book I'm like I really
should be doing better things with my
time and then it's like I'm primed and
ready for my book club book okay it's
kind of like an amazing system I have
here I give the book two stars like it
was bad
that's really bad I know it was just
like short and it wasn't bad but like it
had quite literally no substance and
like not even good smut it was like it
was giving PG-13 it's like how dare I
didn't open up this Kindle for PG-13 and
who recommended it I don't want to drag
her but it was from a recommendation
posted on Instagram by one of our Queens
Liz height oh [__] I thought it was the
snitch no but the snitch sent me the
screenshot from Liz Heights but in Liz's
defense it was just she'd gathered from
her audience she didn't read it herself
so scared to do that so many times I'll
do like these q and A's like tell me
what vibe you're looking for in a book I
will I will give you a recommendation
and there are so many times when it's
like here's a book that I know is that
Vibe I just haven't read it yet but I
will not recommend a book that I haven't
read and I was actually getting to a
place where it's like you know what I
think I actually might just like start
throwing in books I haven't read but
after this experience you've had yeah
and maybe I won't well let me tell you
how I'm constantly recommending books to
people that I haven't read but that
you've read oh okay and I've said good
things yeah no and I just like lie and
pretend like I'm really smart that's
fine I would recommend a book to someone
that you've read like I always recommend
things we never in which to get over
yeah like Lucy score even though I
haven't but I don't want to read like I
do no I say Claudia Margo love this book
it's like their favorite smut book of
the Year yes it's going viral like if
that's what looking for you should
where's the sequel you should read that
sequel
you know I lie and I'm like oh my God
this book was like amazing it's so you
and with the crawdads like I'm always
talking about like I read the book just
because I saw the movie yeah well
crawdad is something you should
recommend to like anyone who's a reader
that's like a real reader that's not me
no no but like maybe some of your
friends yeah perhaps
um so I'm excited to get into it today
um anything else we need to discuss we
still haven't really kind of finalized
plans for our thousandth episode we've
got a lot of good recommendations but
nothing I was really like dying to do
cute stuff yeah I just want to get like
emotional you know yeah there was some
cute stuff wait I saw something that was
like palatable yeah a lot of people said
you know reflecting on our first episode
a lot of people said reflecting on like
our favorite moments our favorite
stories and be like do you know my
memory I know I know it's so hard for us
I don't have the capacity once this show
raps the second we say goodbye goodbye
everything we just said has left my
brain I think that's how I process you
know
oh this is what I liked toast trivia
where we each come up with a set of
questions from previous episodes as a
fun way to remember like what was your
like you know something like
this would be a really easy one like how
did I describe the excuse you girl who
does both sides yeah yeah okay okay
that's cute you could put some together
for me I could put some together for you
okay maybe like five and five okay I
feel like that's cute that's cute
or what was I wearing on the day Jackie
choked oh that's not the show oh right
that's on my plate this is not my plate
or like what did you wear when Derek
peth came on the show my wedding dress
well just the veil and it's an ugly
Topshop shirt yeah
and then like what about like who's your
least favorite guest oh you know what
people always ask me that and I don't
really have an answer but the other day
I remembered my answer I I do and I
wasn't afraid to say it but now I can't
remember or is she afraid no no because
really like we don't have that many
guests that like there's like if
someone's coming I had so many over the
years we probably have had 100 guests
yeah there was someone I remembered it
the other day
[__] it'll come to me I'll tell you guys
I was it was something that I was like
oh yeah I could share that like either I
beef with this person I don't know where
it's like they just were bad and they're
a good person but like this wasn't the
format for them yeah I think actually
that happens a lot because we're so
Niche pop culture like we want to have
people on and they want to come on but
if they don't do pop culture well that's
different for hosting yeah that's
something I actually experi ran into a
little bit when I was casting for your
maternity leave there were so many
people that wanted to come on they're
like I don't do pop culture and like At
first I was like okay but then I was
like
no hard feelings but like no yeah
I understand
um so that's it for me okay we'll keep
thinking about ideas but I think mostly
it's again just gonna be a lot of
sitting and reflecting
um looking forward and looking back and
then being able to call it like our
thousandth episode and then being able
to go around and say oh we've done 1 000
episodes what have you done you know
what did you do today because I recorded
my thousands episode of my podcast the
toast and then I'm ready we'll be like
oh and I recorded 1001 yeah you know
what's so sad
on Friday we won't be together we won't
be together
and that's really hard I'm being asked
to leave
I just I have guessed my houses for the
last two weeks been like a revolving
door nice I can think of BNB and I do
make breakfast on the weekends you too
okay you made breakfast once twice [__]
twice I made the the spread when my
friends were here and then I made your
ass chocolate chip muffins she did and I
made eggs and hash browns she did a
potato I'm so sorry yeah yeah so I'm
really glad that you remembered that no
no I did I I ate another one of the
muffins yesterday how could I forgot
there's the muffins I keep on giving
they're so good they actually get better
with time
that's dramatic but no they really do
wow things they get like um
firmer no
not bouncy but like spongy sponge
okay
um yes I'm being asked to leave tomorrow
and
tomorrow I will leave
oh that's tomorrow yeah that's sad yeah
I didn't think about it as tomorrow
I love you tomorrow yes I do you're only
only a day away two
tomorrow
tomorrow I love you tomorrow you're only
a day
[Music]
[Applause]
I feel like I was really Pleasant what
do you think Pleasant I think that's the
perfect word like it wasn't painful it
was the notes incredible let me hit the
notes I hit the notes
the vocal fire was at a minimum the
notes were hit the fry was minimized it
was pleasant tomorrow show it should be
just in the face of everyone who says
like if you guys don't stop singing
You're Gonna Lose listeners like it's so
annoying we should sing the whole show
that really works for me yeah laughtered
I'd love to sing are you ready to get
into the rest of the show only if we can
sing for the rest of the show I don't
know if I can do the ads while I sing
because then they'll be 10 minutes long
and they'll say that's not what we paid
for 100 but you could write a jingle
I feel like we're constantly writing
Jingles for friends like that we that's
like a fun fact about if you buy an ad
on the show like you might just get a
free jingle yeah this will be in the
industry called added value yeah we're
just like adding value to what you're
paying us to do
it's kind of gorgeous really like
increasing our value in the market and
in these tough Economic Times you've got
to be differentiate yourself apart
really got to show these Brands how you
are going to work for them and how you
are passionate about their brand 100 so
who are we getting passionate about
today litterd after we deliver the fast
five stories that you need to know I'm
so glad you asked because it is a brand
who I believe we've gone above and
beyond for it's
um
[Music]
all right introducing the bed by thuma
handcrafted from eco-friendly high
quality upcycled wood the bed has a
modern minimalist design that helps
Elevate any space it is super supportive
for your mattress it is breathable and
it's made to naturally minimize noise
and create space and the bed is put
together using the Timeless technique of
Japanese joinery so each piece locks
into place which means there are no
tools required no excess Hardware
required for assembly they have clean
lines subtle curves and lifestyle
enhancing details the bed is simple
sophistication for the bedroom the bed
is actually on the opposite side of this
wall behind us Jackie has it in what we
are calling snitches quarters snitches
quarters though my friend slept in
snitches room this weekend uh Rebecca
and Sam they both slept amazingly they
love the bed they specifically called
out the Japanese joinery and I love that
bed in that room it's like so wonderful
it arrives in three big boxes it's
they're easy to maneuver it can take
five minutes to set up you will not want
to kill your partner and they work with
one tree planted to plant one tree for
every bed and nightstand sold the bed
and all the other Essentials are green
guard gold certified so they've met some
of the world's most intensive chemical
emission standards they offer other
bedroom Essentials besides the bed they
have the mattress the nightstand the
side table and they all perfectly
complement the bed they also have
financing options available on their
website create that feeling of checking
into your favorite boutique hotel suite
but at home with the bed by thuma and
now go to thuma.co toast to receive a 25
credit towards your purchase of the bed
plus free shipping in the Continental
go to thuma.co toast that's t-h-u-m-a
dot Co slash toast for 25 credit today's
episode is also brought to you by Noom
another brand that we've been passionate
about here since like day 60. when we
decide to lose weight it's not usually
just about the number on the scale
everyone has their own reasons they
might want to just feel better they
might want to fit into their clothes
they might have like something coming up
that they want to feel their best for
whatever your reason is new weight is
ready to help because they're different
they're not enlawed you know not like
other diets new weight is different they
use psychology to help you understand
your eating habits and they learn how to
make healthier choices every day so you
might discover that you eat because
you're bored or you can't pass up food
just because it's free don't stress
about that NuMe weight can help you
break that cycle and change your habits
for good so they use psychology at noon
weight and that's why they say that
losing weight starts with your brain the
program helps you understand the science
behind your eating choices and why you
have cravings to date NuMe weight has
helped more than 4 million people lose
weight everyone's journey is different
so your daily lessons are going to be
personal lies to you and your goals
whatever those goals may be the program
is super flexible they focus on progress
instead of perfection so if you have a
bad day it's totally fine if you don't
want to give up carbs you don't have to
if you're having cravings new weight can
help you lose weight while still
enjoying your favorite foods it's
realistic it's like you can adapt it
into your everyday life
active first-time numerous lose an
average of 15 pounds in 16 weeks and 95
of customers say that new weight is a
good long-term solution their approach
is grounded in science they've published
more than 30 peer-reviewed scientific
articles describing their methods and
Effectiveness stay focused on what's
important to you with new weights
psychology-based approach sign up for
your trial today at noom.com toast
that's n o o m.com slash toast to sign
up for your trial today and check out
noom's first book it's called the new
mindset it's a deep dive into the
psychology of behavior change it's
available to buy now wherever your books
are sold thank you turdy you're welcome
our first story inside the rampant
culture of sex at ABC News what quote
everyone was sleeping around is that GMA
that's GMA that's TJ and Amy multiple
former employees say there is a quote
rampant culture of sex at ABC News after
ousted GMA 3 co-anchors TJ Holmes and
Amy roback's marriage and career touring
torpedoing Affair made headlines late
last year it was revealed that Holmes
allegedly engaged in at least three
other workplace romances two of which
were with Junior staffers yikes one of
those Junior staffers spoke names uh
Alias Sasha so she's saying Anonymous
spoke to the cut anonymously for an
expose published Tuesday confirming what
a well-placed source implied in an
interview with page six last month that
Holmes and Sasha are then associate
producer in her mid-20s would have sex
in his office our source described
Holmes as being in a position of power
over her but Sasha told the cut she
didn't even think about the power
dynamics at the time because the
networks nightly program on which they
both worked was a pretty scandalous
place though she'd heard rumors that
certain women had been promoted after
having affairs with Executives she said
she was left heartbroken and feeling
like a throwaway object when Holmes who
apparently had shown a crazy amount of
interest in her initially left the
overnight show to focus on GMA her
feelings were Amplified after news of
his other Affairs broke it was just a
pattern she admitted to the outlet
adding that she thought she was special
additionally Sasha claimed that the
executives are more protective of the
company's reputation than they are of
their staffers you know it's funny how
TJ Holmes was fired not for this but for
having an affair with someone who's of
age and can consent and that's like
equal power no these like tawdry affairs
with young staffers were fine with you
yeah and this rampant culture of six
that apparently everybody knows about
that just like is and that's also like
the kind of culture that Matt Lauer that
we like the media is rallying again
right no it's it honestly it's like with
the Matt Lauer thing when we all found
out we were like what the [__] with the
button under his desk and people were
like no if you worked there like you
knew like he was crazy like young girls
were like told not to go near him like
so everyone knows nobody talks about it
and it's like they're all also
advocating against this everybody also
acts shocked right when things come out
but if you work there you're like
you're lying and I just think it's so
funny how like GM not funny but like
moronic how GMA like released so many
statements about this affair with Amy
and like made a whole thing about it
made an example of him doing an
investigation but it's like all these
other things are going on and they're
never investigating any of that and
that's like something worthy worthy of
investigating his relationship with Amy
is like the least interesting thing
about him how do you know what people
would call it irrelevant performative of
course that's exactly what people call
it because it's exactly what it is yeah
muronic Matt Lauer was NBC right
yes like this isn't like an ABC problem
it's like a media problem yeah a media
problem and like a newsroom problem
where everybody's just like getting sexy
no like I could I could see how like you
know late nights early mornings
traveling like it
and that's fine but not when you know
one person is like much older in a
position of Power with like a junior
staffer who's just like doing her rest
yeah and also not when it's gonna lead
to either promotions or firings if
you're having an affair right but if
it's too consenting adults on the same
level yeah but it's like the the rules
for you know intra office relationships
have become so strict ever since like me
too era where it's like you know what
someone higher and someone lower like or
have a relationship and it's like in
certain instances they're like a little
too straight where it's like what about
a budding romance but it's like but
stuff like this goes on stuff like like
this happens yeah and it's like but why
can't those two people who like actually
are in a relationship like just be
together even though like one's
technically the boss so like those HR
rules are meant to implement like and
protect people but the people like the
the Predators almost like they don't
care about your HR rules you know yeah
so you're only affecting like the good
intended people no but it's not even
like Predators it's just like
it's almost like an over correction yeah
a problem that is like still rampant and
it's like the only
people who are like following the rules
are people who would be like in a
relationship and like want to do things
right but they can't be and then
everyone else is like still having sex
on the side totally
um
well I guess it's for the best then that
he wasn't brought back because he seems
to be quite problematic yeah I guess so
and so like we said maybe that's why
yeah maybe like actually fired him the
investigation found more but what about
Amy
yeah that ain't right right
that's kind of rude right
but they're still together so so it's
love I guess this is love like the way I
felt about the story in the beginning
the way I feel about it now like ew you
know yeah I just like don't think it's
of ABC News as like a sexy place
so when you hear there's like a rampant
culture of sex I find it shocking yeah
because I feel like if you work in like
early morning or late night news like
morning Brad morning breath but then
like you you know you suck coffee maybe
week one you're looking gorgeous but
like eventually just roll out of bed to
get to work like you have five minutes
out of bed and settle to the kitchen
right pour yourself a cup of ambition
you're not like you know being glamorous
it's like you work at Cosmo and you can
roll in at nine yeah you're up at four
yeah so again I agree I don't see it as
like this kind of Beacon of sexiness
[Laughter]
maybe that's just us because we don't
have a rampant culture of sex here at
the toast I mean the Brethren might
disagree that's true I mean we do
celebrate Humpty Hump Day quite
voracious right are are we kind of like
this sexy business
do we have a rampant sexual culture here
I'll have to talk to Ben
why because he's a part of our business
like our culture no this is the business
the four of us yeah okay
and I think things are pretty
workplace approach say it yeah we make
jokes sure sure is that a crime no I
mean honestly like thank God that you
are my sister because like if you
weren't I wouldn't be able to have the
[__] imagine if you had like a hot male
co-host I would love that oh my God it
would be a I see how these things happen
it would be a workplace that's rampant
with sexual whatever they said culture
of sex yeah
um and sexual tension
that'd be me do you see I don't know why
this is segwaying to this
um they're making a documentary about HQ
I did oh oh oh oh wrong show wrong Show
Oh wrong show oh thank you thank you so
much I don't care when people ask me who
the worst guest we've ever had on the
toast is thank you Jackie it is Scott
Rogowski he didn't come in the toast
came on the breath it still counts uh
and it was at the peak of HQ and I never
met a bigger dick in my life like he
could not be wasting his time with two
irrelevant uglies like us he was on look
at us now Scott yeah he was on his way
to stardom and we were just mere ants
under his foot like he was so [__]
rude and so condescending and so holier
than that it was so clear that like
everything that was happening was going
right to his head yeah and you could
tell in the interview because I remember
the comments were like whoa we should go
back and find that interview he was so
[__] rude yeah so he's my least
favorite guest and now knowing you know
having personal interest in the matter I
honestly don't know if I would believe
anything he says in the documentary and
I'm so glad you brought this up wait
okay I followed this girl on Tick Tock
and she's like pretty popular she's like
here's you know Day in the Life as a
working actress who's not famous like I
she's like I work all the time I do like
commercials nobody knows who I am but
like I make a living off of being an
actor people learn a lot of things about
acting in industry and sag
um and apparently she was the backup
co-host I don't remember her like if
Scott couldn't do it it was her and then
when Scott left she filled in and she
made a tick tock being like how can they
make a documentary and like literally
didn't even ask me to be a part of it so
now I'm feeling like literally Scott
like championed this documentary well so
the trailer for the documentary came out
and it focuses on like the founders
Scott maybe some other people that
worked there and the success of the show
and I had like so many thoughts first
like Scott like starts to say how the
founders were you know interested in
having a successful company and then
they were maybe a little like jealous
that he was the face of their company
sure Scott sure uh and then they also
were like saying how you know from the
beginning the sewing like this Discord
between the founders and how like one
founder wanted this and one founder
wanted that and then they grow so fast
and somebody died and they couldn't like
build it fast enough a lot and like if
there was beef between the founders like
okay that's not why HQ flopped like no
H2 flop because like that's what happens
to flashes in the past and then they
burn Squirtle yeah like everyone every
morning for one week played Wordle and
now people I play it sometimes like it's
not something everyone does every
morning and shares it's like just a game
now it's like yeah like any other game
that you play on your phone like right
and HQ like you can only really get
people hooked on an app for so long that
has so many problems before people stop
playing
yeah it wasn't even the problems it was
just like we played and now we're on to
the next big thing like yeah that's how
the internet works especially for like
small things it's not like it's an app
that you could spend your whole day on
like it was very five minutes and then
people moved on with their lives yeah no
a documentary I don't think is in order
here no like so they're gonna like ex
like expose you know and explain why HQ
didn't work out but H2 didn't work out
because it was never going to work out
because like when you rise so quickly
like you fall so quickly that's just it
and it's also just the nature of the
game yeah but I am so glad you brought
that up because
first of all I don't even know if I ever
would watch a documentary because like
literally who cares no it's like
literally I don't like I don't need to
explore like the H like what one month
in pop culture right like so not that I
was like ever and so inclined to watch
it but I can't now because knowing what
I know about Scott he was so like
egotistical and him saying that like the
founders were jealous that he became the
famous like well if they wanted to be
the face they would have it's literally
I could have hit you to the curb at any
minute right and they would have started
hosting like question mark it's nice to
see that Scott hasn't changed he's
literally my nemesis
and he doesn't even know it he was so
rude like he made me feel so small
physically because he was so tall but
like he was just so like
ugh I hated him yeah I'm gonna go back
and find that episode where he was so
[__] right I could have told you yeah
he wouldn't stand the test of time yeah
I wonder if he's so Macho now irrelevant
what's he up to check his Instagram
making a documentary about his five
minutes of fame literally tell me you're
a narcissist without telling me you're a
narcissist well he didn't make the
documentary like someone it honestly
seemed poor HQ it seemed like it was
honestly directed by Scott Rogowski
well that's because he's the face of it
you know
are you ready for our next story yeah
which is really some wonderful
podcasting news oh Julia Louis dreyfus's
first podcast will glean life lessons
from women over 70. is she hosting it
she is hosting it it is called wiser
than me and Julia Louis Dreyfus who is
62 will have candid and witty
conversations with women over 70
according to podcast Network La Monada
media I like that which is producing the
show it will be a 10-part series slated
to be released in the spring of 2023
including you know notable over 70 women
she said in a statement Julia Louis and
in our culture older women are rarely
seen or heard what a shame we are
missing out on the wisdom and
experiences of a huge portion of the
population I want to hear from these
older women I want to talk to them I
want to know how they navigate aging and
their tips for a life well lived how
they did it how they do it and
everything in between these are the
conversations I will explore in my new
podcast wiser than me I like that it's
hard to separate yourself as an
interviewer as a podcast faster
especially when you're just like a
celebrity and everyone has one so like
to kind of Niche yourself into like
older women I like that and it's true
like we don't listen to the to the older
Generations enough no definitely not
like normal especially not older women
right when it's like we have everything
to learn from them they know everything
you know everything I mean that one
episode we did with Norma Kamali like we
were obsessed yeah just so much wisdom
being shared and I think this is such a
great idea I mean the thing the part
about like how uh their tips for aging
like I'm not really interested and I do
find that to be like so
maybe they'll find like a different way
to talk about it but it's like aging is
a part of a natural part of life and not
something that should be like so
circumvented you know there's that old
saying like yeah getting old is hard but
the alternative is worse yeah but I
think maybe what she was trying to say
is like not dealing with like here's not
like giving tips on like how to you know
skin care but like I think maybe for
women it's like um it's emotional uh
maybe she means like how to deal with
you know if your whole life like your
values put on your looks and then when
you start to get older people start to
dismiss you that's what I'm saying like
I think she'll come at it from a
different angle not like what are you so
tired do you use yeah no because that's
like it like minimizes women yeah and
jld's not like that no she's not like
that I hope she has May musk yeah I was
trying to think like who are
inspirational women is like a really
specific number she has Jane Fonda oh as
one writer Isabelle Allende and
photographer friendly bowitz oh and Chef
and author Ruth Ruth Reichel I don't
know much about friendly boots but every
time what about the one who's similar
Annie Leibowitz
um and I don't really know what no I was
looking for Fran Fran's perfect yeah I
don't really know like what friendly
bowitz does or like what her spot in our
culture is but every time I like read
something that she's written or like
watch an interview of her I'm obsessed
author public speaker and occasional
actor she's known for her sardonic
social commentary on American life as
filtered through her New York City
sensibilities
like when you hear her speak she's like
she's on the money I wish she could have
had Queen Elizabeth on that would have
been beautiful would love to hear her
tips on Aging would love to hear her
tips on life on everything yeah most
actually I feel like you know a lot of
her experience is not relatable and you
know I'd love to hear like tips on
motherhood yeah balancing you know work
and life right even though like I don't
know from Queen Elizabeth because like
she would admit that she put work ahead
of her life and motherhood like isn't
that what Charles is always complaining
about right classic Charles classic
um did you see they've set a date for
his coronation I
it's Carnation day it is I'm so excited
when is it I don't know but they said it
can't wait it's like in a long time
can't wait which is gonna perform not
even for Charles B carnated like I'll be
fine but just like to see the uh the
band back together again back together
obviously the Wales is who have been
like extra cute recently I think they've
had to step up their game they've also
been like extra quiet yeah but like
they've been you know like I guess
they're they're always super cute but
like they in their matching outfits and
like they've been putting out really
cute pictures which is like that's their
job and that's what they do but I do
feel like it's to combat silently combat
the negativity negativity yeah
um so check this out
wiser than me I will I'm actually we'll
probably tune into the friendly bullets
episode yeah and she's got to get mang
musk I'm sorry yeah like how do you
raise a boy Genius let us know and then
like also you know have like a second
coming of a career right after 60 and be
a model right
are you ready for our next story yeah
why Adam DeVine despite is to speak out
amid the Adam Levine Scandal he decided
I don't know what I said so I'm not
gonna combat you it was a big it was a
mouthful you want to say it again no
okay in the midst of Adam Levine's
cheating scandal last September Adam
DeVine shared a social media post
clarifying that he was not in fact the
singer at the center of the allegations
as Divine recently explained his public
quip only came after being a big case of
mistaken identity I wouldn't say it's
like a big case of my steak Knife are
you okay there's a lot of words I would
say like this is funny but I don't know
if people were like actually confusing
him I do think like this is what he said
Rachel Ray Rachel Roy yeah yeah that was
actually like confusing people didn't
know who Rachel Roy was so they went to
their like first Rachel Ray where it's
like Adam Levine is more famous than
Adam Divine I'm not always thinking
about him Divine when I mean to be
thinking of Adam Levine and actually
never
but this is what he said he went on
caller daddy and he said I would never
I'm not big in inserting myself into
someone else's drama I'm like this guy
is already going through it and so I was
steering clear respect then he said I
was getting so many people that were
just dming me being like how [__]
dare you and then you look at their page
and I'm like this person does not follow
me they have no idea they are not
Workaholics fans they have not seen my
movies they were truly a Maroon 5 fan
and now hate me on accident I was
legitimately getting hundreds of DMS
well that sucks I know but like if
they're a Maroon 5 then how could they
be so stupid yeah no it's it's actually
mind-blowing this is just a testament to
the stupidity of so many people It's
upsetting for sure
so he put out a clarification a
statement addressing
um
that addressing the you know confusion
and saying just want to post that me and
my wife Chloe Bridges and I are doing
great I'm obsessed by the way
he's a different guy and a worse singer
we are however naming our future baby
summer hold on I have to
bless you I'm obsessed with the fact
that Adam DeVine is married to Donna
Ladonna from The Carrie Diaries like I
don't know you know what she's up to now
but like to me she will always be Donna
Ladonna Austin Butler was in that show
too that show is a moment in time I
cannot recommend people watch it enough
um and I love that they got married
she's like so gorgeous and they look
such a nice relationship yeah because he
seems like a nice funny guy every now
and then I'll just like go to his
Instagram like check up like I don't
follow him but just like sometimes he'll
cross my mind and I find that he has
such a nice life and I feel like he's a
really good husband like I actually I
really like Adam DeVine he had a recent
comedy special on Netflix and it was
actually very good yeah we enjoyed it
and we were just listening to the Pitch
Perfect album we were because it's a fun
thing to listen to with kids it is
what is that
I've been working for the weekend no not
anymore I feel the electricity it's like
you know how sometimes you don't hear
like I don't know the words of the song
and then they're coming to you wait but
then that because I wanted to go I've
got the magic in me
every time I touch that track it turns
into gold that's your question if you
could be a treblemaker or a Barton Bella
which one would you want it to have been
kind of a trip with Trevor like they
were [__] lit and they were popular
and they had a hot tub they said they
all had to like revolve around Buster
but but
I feel like it was really competitive
like you couldn't get a solo because
like Buster has no you know Talent grows
you look at the Barton Bellas like they
just needed like I could have taken
control and gave myself all the solos
because they were so chaotic Big Fish
small pond yeah but it's like I want to
swim with the big fish yeah
um but back to this call her daddy thing
so the the announcement for who was
going to be this week's guest was really
confusing because they intentionally
tried to make it look like it was going
to be Adam Levine yes and then bahati
like so she posted this clip that was
like it was just Alex talking we didn't
see who the guest was and she says you
know I was she was really serious like
nostrils flaring like she was angry and
she was like I was you know a really big
Maroon 5 fan but like how many times did
you cheat on your wife and we're like
wow like she got Adam living in the hot
seat and like he's answering for his
sins that's crazy and then people
started like Pokemon's being like wait
like they didn't share the thing and
she's kind of acting like an actress
like she wouldn't actually say that so
then people were just guessing who it
was going to be but then Behati Prince
Lou commented on that teaser being like
lol in all caps and it's like well she's
talking about like your husband cheating
on you like is that funny
um and then it ends up being Adam DeVine
which I feel like
it's kind of like a rude promo like no I
didn't get Adam Levine I got Adam DeVine
you know it's not as good but why did
Behati Prinsloo comment I think to let
everyone know because I think before she
commented people really thought it was
Adam Levine so like to let everyone know
like this is not Adam without having to
say like this is not Adam right but like
she really poked the hole in yeah in the
in the people who like really thought it
was him I just found the whole thing
confusing yeah it was confusing but then
Alex posted pretty quickly afterwards
that it was Adam DeVine I think because
it got so confusing yeah yeah okay okay
yeah well I actually really like Adam
DeVine yeah and so he's not Adam Levine
I have to say like if you really are a
moon fry fan who got confused like
you're dumb you're dumb you're dumb and
you're not okay who are two celebrities
like you whether it's like the way they
look or their names that you get
confused oh there are so many
like Evan Rachel Wood and Evanescence no
you know Evanescence his name is Amy
Evanescence for me that's that's two no
either Evan Rachel Wood and like Rachel
Lee Cook like three named girlies
they're the same people anime yeah and I
wouldn't know either of them like I
couldn't pick either of them out of a
lineup
um
I'm trying to think and when I was
younger I could not tell apart Sandra
Bullock and Justin Julia Roberts yeah no
but I've got them down pat but there are
really
so many I feel like we're Chris is no no
they don't even I'm not going there okay
that we're always talking about people
who are the same person yeah
but I guess I they're so unmemorable
yeah that is what it is it is what it is
are you ready for our next story if it's
the next story that's brought to you by
Jenny Kane it is uh support for today's
episode comes from Jenny Kane with
Valentine's Day around the corner it's
time to treat yourself to a Jenny Kane
luxury what's better what's a better way
to show self-love than with a much
needed home refresh featuring true
featuring new handcrafted furniture and
Home Decor from Jenny Kane you can make
any home your dream home with Jenny
Kane's Timeless and Ultra cozy pieces
from throws and pillows beds and
nightstands Jenny excuse me Jenny King's
products are always worth the investment
and truly built to last forever find
your Forever Decor pieces with our
exclusive 15 off discount when you go to
jennykane.com and use the code toast
that'll give you 15 off your entire
order whatever your budget is you know
you can find something at Jenny Kane
um some of the smaller pieces like their
slippers or their candles are really
really nice and like really luxurious
and then if you want to go up all the
way up to their Furniture like they have
really something for everyone it's such
a good brand I feel like if your partner
wants to buy you something he's like I
don't even know where to start just send
him to Jenny Kane like there's nothing
he could buy a Jenny Kane that you
wouldn't love it's like the throw
pillows the blankets I have so much
Jenny Kane in my house so many candles I
have a lot of her sweaters I have a lot
of her slippers throw blankets
um it's really uh it's really everything
of the story like once Jenny puts her
stamp of approval on something it's
everything so the pillows and throws
from linen and alpaca to super soft
cashmere these handcrafted textiles are
versatile they're durable and they're
perfect for a sofa update a bedroom
refresh or a simple accented Edition
it's one of their best-selling products
the alpaca basket weave throw so cozy
and comfortable you definitely need one
for every room in your house in addition
to the Cozy decor and pieces Jenny also
has I'm on a first name basis it's just
Jenny now
um Jenny Gaines all his money connected
it could never say Jenny Jenny Kane has
your aesthetic and high-end Kitchen
Essentials like the Pacific dinnerware
and serve wear with pieces starting at
just 25 it's the easiest way to
completely elevate your dining room and
kitchen find your Forever pieces at
jennykane.com home our listeners get
that 15 off your first order when you
use code toast to check out that's 15
off your first order at
j-e-n-n-i-k-a-y-n-e.com slash home promo
code toast treat yourself because you
deserve it today's episode is also
brought to you by boom branch stay cozy
all winter long with a set of buttery
soft sheets from Bowling Branch you know
what I'm so glad I have a personal
anecdote to support today's ad so the
first couple of days I was here I wasn't
sleeping good and I was like damn
balloon branch is like not the vibe and
I love bowling Branch I'm always sitting
on bowling Branch at home here and then
I went to change my sheets and I
realized you put a duvet cover on that
was not bowling Branch it's true so I
went into the linen closet I found my
king-size bowling Branch duvet cover and
now I've been sleeping much better Ben
was like there's something wrong with
the sheets he knew too and he doesn't
even notice [__] like that damn sorry I
failed you I'm not sorry because now I
feel like I can give an even more
emphatic and more purpose-driven read
for bowling Branch it's true it was a
trick bowl and Branch are made with the
softest 100 organic cotton you've ever
felt it's the kind of quality you'll
immediately feel the signature hem
sheets from Bowling Branch are their
best seller for a reason they use the
highest quality threads on Earth their
sheets are made from slogan organic
cotton for a superior softness and a
better night's sleep they feel buttery
to the touch they're super breathable
and they're perfect for cooler and
warmer months they've loved by millions
of sleepers they're so luxurious and
they have over 10 000 rave reviews they
come in 10 versatile colors and sizes
from twin beds up to California King
they're designed to feel incredible for
all sleepers and they're made without
toxins pesticides formaldehyde and other
harsh chemicals they fit the deepest of
mattress they're labeled with top and
bottom tags so making your bed is no
longer an Olympic sport make the best of
bedtime with bowling Branch get 15 off
your first set of sheets when you use
promo code toast at bowl and branch.com
that's bowling Branch
b-o-l-l-a-n-d branch.com promo code
toast thank you turdy yet welcome our
next story Meghan Markle and Prince
Harry will be deposed in Samantha
markle's defamation case yikes Megan and
Harry will be deposed in her estranged
half-sister Samantha Marco's defamation
case a Florida judge ruled on Tuesday
the judge dismissed Megan's motion to
avoid testimonies ruling that the
Duchess of Sussex quote does not show
that unusual circumstances justify the
requested stay or that prejudice or an
undue burden will result if the court
does not impose a stay Megan does not
satisfy the high standard required to
stay Discovery pending the resolution of
a dispositive motion Samantha had
demanded that Megan and Harry be deposed
in separate interviews claiming in court
documents that to date The Duchess has
not agreed to schedule one single
deposition Samantha also requested the
depositions of her father Thomas Markle
her daughter Ashley Hale who we are now
familiar with from the documentary I
liked her former Royal aide Jason noff
an online security expert Christopher
boozy yikes Samantha is suing Megan for
defamation based on quote demonstrably
false and malicious statements made to a
worldwide audience during the Oprah win
a free interview in March 2021 she
accused Megan of orchestrating a
campaign to quote defame and Destroy her
and Thomas's reputation and credibility
the suit alleged that Megan did so quote
in order to preserve and promote the
false rags to royalty narrative that she
is fabricated about her life to the
royal family and the worldwide media
Samantha further claimed that Megan told
lies to destroy Samantha's reputation
that have subjected her to humiliation
shame and hatred on a worldwide scale
okay I don't know if they were lies but
I would say she's humiliated and shamed
on the worldwide scale so I feel like
first of all it is so hard to win a
defamation case it's borderline
impossible in America
um and look at Johnny Depp and it's
beyond expensive I mean Johnny Depp like
almost went broke from that whole thing
how has Samantha Markle like paying for
all this it's it's most people even if
you have a good case most people will
avoid litigating when it comes to
defamation because it's such a long
process it is so expensive yeah I don't
know how she's paying for it but she
must really think that she has the keys
and I'm sure that she knows
that the odds are not in her favor yeah
she's also seeking 75 000 in Damages
queen go bigger like yeah that's like I
mean based like let's say what she's
saying is true and that the Megan
interview whatever based on the scale of
the interview the damages would be more
yeah that seems like a low amount of
Damages but like I think you're gonna
say 75 million right
I don't know but she really has been
smeared like no she has I will say some
of that is her own fault but like a lot
of that is her own fault everything that
Megan said is true then like we're you
know we're just reacting to the truth
but like if all of that is not true and
this woman has just been like completely
but you know when I see Samantha Markle
I'm like oh my God she's crazy I my
perception of that is built on like just
seeing her not stop doing interviews
what if it's her like trying to clear
her name I know but what did Megan say
about her I don't even remember to me
the Samantha Markle of it all is the
least interesting thing about the whole
Oprah like I don't even care because
honestly from the second she came out
I'm like oh man this [__] is crazy okay
so from this is from 2022 when she filed
soon the defamatory implication is that
the plaintiff had no relationship
whatsoever with her sister Megan they
were virtual strangers and that
plaintiff has created a lucrative career
selling Paul's story
when she knows nothing about the
defendant's childhood Megan did say that
like she doesn't know this woman at all
why is she coming forward Samantha goes
on to accuse Megan of bashing their
father Thomas Markle in an attempt to
sell the world the false rags to royalty
Narrative of her life Megan quote this
is from the statement Megan falsely
claimed that a she essentially raised
herself from virtual poverty B she was
forced from the age of 13 to work in a
series of low-paying jobs to make ends
meet
and further accusing Megan of misleading
the public regarding Thomas's absence
from the wedding hmm
I mean you know what's so great about
the justice system is we will find out
she went to trial of by jury
oh my God she is she a lawyer like how
I'm I'm to be the most interesting part
about all this is like the back end
Logistics like how was Samantha Markle
paying for a legal team yeah especially
a legal team that's skilled enough and
big enough to go up against Harry and
Megan who have kind of unlimited
resources yeah well maybe it's not like
a big bad legal team but maybe the law
is on their side or so they feel yeah
you know it'll be interesting I will
keep up with this uh
this case yeah hopefully take a while
hopefully it'll be televised oh my gosh
probably not though for whatever reason
because things are different it's
Florida is that what it said Florida but
like the same reason that oh no Amber
and Johnny's wasn't it was like but that
was because Virginia
is that it basically it's based on the
state I believe but it's like say
there's like two Rand lay people who are
like yeah but no one's bringing a camera
to televise because we don't care if
they wanted to yeah no and I actually
feel like there are channels who like
play it you know what I mean yeah Court
TV yeah like too irrelevance that it
exists yeah
that's how like you know when we get
documentaries there's always footage and
maybe it wasn't airing at the time or
people didn't care but there's like a
catalog of footage got it okay so we'll
see what happens yeah are you ready for
our fifth and final story Bruno it's the
fifth and final are you excited he's
excited because that means when we're
done you could have scratchies
I think Theo's not turned towards me he
would see oh yeah
oh wow okay you said the scratches were
not up to the caliber that I desired
okay bye great I got my chair back
what's the story girly
sassy baby oh yeah it's going Instagram
official with her man's Jaden Hustler
Jaden Hustler and stassi baby are
Instagram official after weeks of
teasing their relationship the couple
shared their love to the grid over the
weekend he 21 posted a gallery
25. posted a galleries of selfies of him
and his girlfriend on Saturday getting
cuddly in the spare well in the pics the
singer-songwriter and baby
no it's like her actual last name but
she's sassy baby to me post side by side
him in a little tyke gray shirt and
black pants and stassi in a tight black
bodysuit
so this is interesting so for those who
don't know I feel like you probably
don't know
Jayden Hustler is and why the People
magazine article is actually leading
with Jaden Hauser because the headline
is Jaden and stuff so Jaden is a major
tick tocker he's from like the OG High
Pass days like he's part of like the
Addison Charlie Bryce crew he was one of
those guys yeah Bryce Hall and what
about Strife no stress wasn't in the
high pass
um he's one of the ogs he was dating
this girl Maddie and they were like the
couple of the house yada yada and then
this other couple Jaden I feel like we
spoke about them a lot Jaden and Nessa
remember Nessa Onessa so they were like
these two couples and then it turned out
that Nessa and Jaden from the two
couples
started dating Affair
um it wasn't clear it wasn't you know it
wasn't totally kosher you know but these
kids are 17. so then Jaden and Nessa
started dating and everyone was like not
okay but then it turned out like they
were like OTP they were they're both
singers they're both like really emo
like and you know it was it was good and
then they broke up and it was like so
confusing
um now I guess he's eating stassi baby I
know way too much about these kids but
I'm spending all my time on Tick Tock I
might as well like provide something of
value here at the toast and now he gets
he's eating sassy yeah which is
definitely like you know good for him
yeah like older woman New Circle New
Circle she's gorgeous I kind of love
this for him yeah for him I don't know
if I love it for her yeah I feel like
straws not I stuffed hasn't had like
like a big relationship like to because
stats he's like like we know her but a
lot of people she's just Kylie's friend
whatever but she's like a businesswoman
and she's kind of her own celebrity now
and I think the next thing she really
needs is like a major relationship well
maybe this will be good for her like
with the youngins yeah like oh Jaden's
who's Jaden's girlfriend they'll like go
and find her but no this can't be our
final destination she needs an A-list
honestly I've been at her to the list
even though I know she's not single
currently but like she's sugarless she
will be soon and she's good for the list
she's really eligible she runs in
fabulous Circle she's gorgeous and she
could like handle like a really
successful man man because like you see
how she is with Kylie yeah she's
comfortable is there anyone on the list
who we think would be good for her
um let me pull up my list because it's
been a while okay here we go Stussy baby
Chris Evans no I think he's like dating
someone but he's always dating like a
normie Shawn Mendes
I don't see it but I don't see it but
this guy kind of looks like Shawn Mendes
it's also a good age this guy looks like
Jaden something like Shawn Mendes like
that's what she needs she needs
something like yeah Harry Styles yes I
always went to Harry single now yeah
um drop a comment who do you think Saucy
baby should date well you know she dated
Tyler Cameron for like a day remember
that no yeah yeah they were like rumored
for like a minute okay and every once in
a while she'll be linked or like a
picture a cute picture with emerge of
her and Rob obsess
obsessed with remember they were like
leaving the club in each other but I
don't think they were hooking up they
were just like being friends right
family friends and like maybe you know
helping each other walk right sort of
thing which I'm obsessed with I'm UPS we
need you know we need in 2023 Riley and
stars could be sisters well I think
we're all kind of in agreement there's
we're kind of going through like a very
stale Kardashian era like nothing
they're doing is like really giving I
think it's on Rob to save the family so
I think now is really what we need is a
Rob comeback I think that is one of very
few things that could really catapult
them back to like their pre-2022 success
and I think honestly it's he needs to
like it's his turn to say like everyone
has is down there to step up he slacked
for years but he still like enjoys the
fruits no but the thing is with Robin I
think why everyone's okay with him like
not I know he's I can't handle it like
the fame and and I think he struggled
with addiction like no I know they they
they're okay with it because it protects
them I think where they feel like
annoyed with Courtney is different
because like Courtney really enjoys all
the fruits and everything holding up her
end she is Court corny's actually really
not bothering me no like she's just in
her happy place like she's scoring high
right now I agree and like I think what
her and Travis's relationship like is
great for the family and they need a
similar relationship like to bring to
revive yeah we're saying it could be raw
but it won't be let's like I know and
that's what's best for his mental health
so like I'll I'll have it
um it could be Kendall yeah it won't be
it should be Chloe it could be Chloe it
can't really be Kim no when like I think
she already did that the thing she like
she brought the family back with Kanye
yeah and so like you can't do it twice
remember there were rumors like Brad
Pitt was dating like Courtney or Chloe
like I liked that that time that's kind
of what the family needs
yeah they need to go big yeah like
something they have to I'm sure they're
working on something I think they know
they're kind of in their flop era
and I'm curious what they have in the
works Chloe and Elon obsessed like
something like that like [__] crazy
something crazy that like they could
bring in like that's why I was singing
Brad Pitt like someone who's Larger than
Life who we don't really get access to
like bring them in like we see him in
videos and like maybe on the show in the
corner like for them to humanize someone
you know yeah that's like their
trademark thing yeah I love that or like
Kendall and Harry Styles yeah that's
what everyone it's so obvious honestly
I'm not I don't really ship it no I chip
like you could find me shipping no you
find me on the ship with me and Harry
but I also like don't really think that
they're a good match
the right match so I'm not gonna like
get like I'm not like sitting here
waiting for them to get back together
but like if that's what they chose like
how I'd be here you know I'm sure I
would enjoy the photos and Kylie's like
kind of single now too yes they kind of
all are except for Courtney yeah they
need to like they need to go on grouper
stop and like so you need to get four
a-listers like friends and they need to
go on a group date yeah who's like a
crew of like eligible A-list a-listers
like who's Brad Pitt's friends with
that's single I don't like this wouldn't
work because they're all married but
like the Jonas Brothers
I like that a grouper or what about like
the wahlbergs what are they doing now
and they're much older like they need it
all Donny's married Mark is married
they're all married
um they need a family the gronkowskis
he has like a bunch of Brothers
but Jason's very married Travis is not
Travis is not
but they need to stay away from athletes
true it's it's a todrey
space
okay let me just think of a couple more
famous siblings then we can move on or
even like a boy band
yeah or Man Band so bands are like not a
thing yeah a man band like Chris Martin
is like Mumford
he's married to Carrie Mulligan
rats I know
everyone's kind of Taken it's coming
season you know turdy let's go let's
direct our efforts to Nashville
yeah
the thing with Nashville like country
boys they're all wiped up yeah like it's
a part of their culture you know yeah
dirt fun the one you can't live without
get a ring let your knee hit the ground
do what you love and call it work and
throw a little money in the plate at
church send your prayers up and your
roots down deep add a few links to your
family tree watch their pencil marks in
the grass in the yard all grow up as the
truth yeah they all sing about like
Faith and family they're not saying it
all goes by real quick you can't buy
happiness
but you can buy dirt obsessed and that's
really like I feel like the Kardashians
would hear that would be like true yeah
true true and true yeah the kind of like
country Family Values they do are they
like cowgirls they all say like they
want to give it all up and move to the
farm right right they all say it right
Kylie needs a cowboy
needs a goblin
and there's some eligible younger
National Guardians Kylie and Brad
Eldridge Kylie and Morgan Wallen
that's it that's the one that's the one
oh my God
so those are the Fast Five you certainly
did not need to know them but we had a
good time I had it like Kylie Morgan
Wallen is going to get me through my
darkest days yeah obsessed a blast
obsessed but the show's not over because
it's Wednesday and we have three
toasters in desperate need of our help
and our first tier toasters is a girl
having trouble with her when she boss
and the bosses is giving wench-like
behavior
um so again every Wednesday is Our
advice segment it's called deer toasters
and if you ever want to write in of
course your submission is always
Anonymous email dear toasters gmail.com
and we will do our best to get your
submission right on air if we have read
your submission on air [__] send us
an update okay it's unacceptable I
scoured that stupid email account for
hours yesterday looking for an update
for someone why didn't you search update
I did okay so why did it take you hours
because there was only a couple emails
that said update and they were like I
promise I'll update
okay when she doubting me so then I had
to just go through my hands anybody
replied to themselves went down to you
you're right hey Jackson Claude how you
doing I'm a gen Z toaster hero oh did
you find a song Oh am I your big sis
um I'm in need of some advice about my
new boss I work at my College's gym as a
spin instructor and I just got a new
boss at the beginning of the semester
it is wacky to say the least within one
day of meeting me she asked me for a
ride home and then made me come inside
her house and handed me her dog's dog
leash so I could walk her dog
within the one week that I have known
her she has told me that I have a
personality that is too big and needs to
be reigned in she referred to me as her
dog's boyfriend and asked me to drive
her two hours to the airport the most
recent offense was that when discussing
an inappropriate client who made a
comment about my body she turned around
and said well yeah you're robust but who
cares am I being too sensitive or does
this lady have no boundaries what do I
do do I just ignore it I love my job and
I don't want to quit so please help
oh my God so either like you obviously
like next time she asks you for a ride
no yeah no you don't owe her a ride and
you keep doing it like you get into the
habit of her thinking it's acceptable
yeah no you don't you can say no to all
of those extra it's not like she's
asking you to do things like in the
workplace like right no no I won't walk
your dog and like you're a college
student like you have classes you have
exams you have homework you have a
million excuses I'm sorry I have study
groups so stop doing all those extra
things for her but in terms of like that
comment that's unacceptable especially
work at a gym like [__] off if it like
really made you uncomfortable like you
shouldn't maybe tell someone higher up
but I don't want you to lose your job
either that's like a great gig for a
college student and she shouldn't ruin
it for you so either if you can't like
ignore her and like just tuck her away
and just be like okay irrelevant ugly
bye
um report it yeah but you can't really
like report giving her a ride because
it's like well you don't have to give
her well you could report the body
comment It's always important just to at
least start a file like if you're having
trouble with someone at work like if you
come to them at the end of the year she
did all this
consistently be reporting it and you
know what like you didn't do anything
wrong so I wouldn't worry about you
getting fired report it
all the things that you can say no to
say no to
um
and just keep a record you know that's
what they say keep a record
yeah for it and also just like stay the
[__] away from her so she doesn't think
like oh I need someone to help me today
let me call that girl yeah like you want
to think like no you're not easy you're
that girl who's never around yeah you're
that girl who's got so much going on
yeah because she's so fabulous dates
trips to the cape trips to the cape her
social events calendar is so booked I'll
ask someone else to drive in the airport
maybe I'll call a taxi maybe maybe make
yourself completely unavailable in
anything that isn't work related
all right next up hey there girly girls
love you guys so much I'm in need of
some help I recently got engaged to a
total page on this past Christmas
however I don't love my engagement ring
for reference it's white gold which
looks silver and I'm a gold girly
through and through I have no idea why
he picked something other than gold
since it's all I wear in jewelry like I
don't own a silver piece at all I am
contemplating getting it gold-plated
because this white gold just isn't me
and I'm not in love with it it actually
bugs me that he did this because it's
like he hasn't been paying attention or
had him picked up that I'm a gold
jewelry wearer and we've been together
for seven years please what do I do am I
being such a [__] or am I justified in
wanting to make this ring Perfect Since
I'm the one looking at it every day I
love the cut and everything else it's
truly just the color okay that's really
great that you love the cut and
everything else because we can work with
this the cheapest thing I think to
change is the color of your band yeah
and I wouldn't be offended that like he
didn't know that you wear gold jewelry
same like if you listen to yesterday's
patreon episode like they don't know
they don't know anything like a man
wouldn't notice Like a Rock flying at
his head until it was too late he's
certainly not noticing if I ask Ben but
the only thing is like typically when
someone gets in
but I also kind of like a man taking
initiative I saw this beautiful ring and
it reminded me of you unfortunately it
wasn't the right choice but I do like
that he made a choice no and I feel like
you can tell him to be like by the way
like I'm thinking about
um just having the the ring gold-plated
reset reset and by the way if he's like
Angry like that's a red flag like chill
um so I feel like it's like kind of a
good test you know yeah you could also
like take the original band because it
might have like some meaning and like
repurpose it and just make it into like
a wedding band that you wear on your
other hand mixing like golden it's like
gold is cool so I feel like you could
wait find a way to work that in but if
you take the initiative of like I'm just
gonna switch out the band I love the
ring um I love you yeah like and you'll
pay for it like I think that that's okay
I think that that's okay too and he
might hurt him a little bit like if you
know he
I don't know it's been it's been like
three months you're gonna engage on
Christmas like two months yeah I can't
imagine like on the one hand it's like
sounds beautiful like can't you just
learn to love it
you gotta look at it every day and it's
like a reflection of you like I feel
like an engagement ring is really like
the person in a ring yeah and if it's
not you it's it's not you I have to
imagine like if he went through all the
trouble of like getting it and spending
the money on it he would want you to be
happy yeah it's meant to be a gift like
you're not wearing it to make him happy
so [__] true so it's meant to be a
gift so like make the gift what you want
it to be yeah I just think if you're the
one who's gonna go through all the hoops
and pay for it right I I really think
that you can do what you want yeah no
you're on it's not like you want to
return the whole ring you don't like the
stoner so that's what I was gonna say
like the the detail that you want
changed is like probably the least big
of a deal so it's really okay but just
be open be honest yeah no one ever
regretted telling the truth
is that the truth no I'm definitely
regretting there's a part of me that's
like if you just changed it and didn't
tell him what do you know
what do you know but oh I mean sorry I
got my ring reset I did not like the
setting when do you do it I think maybe
before I even got married like during
the engagement yeah sure people like
don't remember true um but I did get a
reset I don't even know if I told Ben
what I paid for it myself it was the
band was just really thick and I wanted
like a really thin one yeah so I I like
all the diamonds in the band are the
same diamonds I just got a new Platinum
Band yeah it was just too heavy yeah
I think that that's fine then and it's
crazy how resetting your ring like
changes the ring entirely it's like I
mean it wasn't cheap but it's much
better than like getting a new diamond
um and it's a really kind of low-cost
relatively low-cost way of giving your
ring New Life yeah a new ring I remember
when I got it I was like oh my God I
opened it I was like my friend Anna did
I'm like you sent me the wrong ring I
didn't even notice it didn't recognize
her I didn't recognize my own ring so
that's exciting you have something
you're getting a new piece of jewelry
like it really looks so different I'm
excited for you all right third and
final dear toasters
hey Jackson Claude I'm a long time
toaster and breather did you see the
Scott Rogowski episode and I don't know
what I would do if I couldn't listen to
you Queens every day thank you all right
let me get into it I'm going on vacation
with my boyfriend's family in a couple
months we've been dating for about two
years I love him dearly and I love his
family too I'm sure I'm so grateful and
excited that they invited me to join
them on their family trip coincidentally
my aunt lives right near where we'll be
staying I haven't seen her in about a
year and I thought it would be fun to
see her while we're there but when I
brought it up to my boyfriend to see if
a visit with her might fit into the
schedule of our trip he acted kind of
offended about it while he didn't
outright saying no he basically told me
that it would be inappropriate and rude
towards his parents who are bringing me
on their trip with them and my
delusional slash out of line and
thinking it would be okay to go see my
aunt my boyfriend is normally very chill
and easy going about things so I was
surprised by this reaction I don't want
to offend his parents or his family but
I also would feel bad if I was there and
never attempted to see my aunt help what
should I do I see both sides I kind of
do too but like at the end of the day
like it's [__] crazy to like be
staying down the street from your aunt
and not go see her now it's different if
like you want your aunt to come to
dinner with everyone I know if you want
to sit down and go see your aunt you're
totally fine in doing that you
definitely have to be um cautious
because like you don't it's like their
family families get weird in
territorials like it's their family trip
you can't be inserting your family into
their family but if you say like oh
everyone's going for a walk I'm just
gonna go run and see my aunt for an hour
Jason you want to come yeah that
wouldn't offend me but I could
see a little bit where her boyfriend's
coming from but it's like we didn't
bring you here to go see your aunt but
it's just like you're not a prisoner
like and like it's kind of crazy like if
you don't live near someone who's your
family and you literally happen to be
staying five minutes away from them it's
that's rude not to go see them
yeah but you could say like I'm here
with my boyfriend's family and they they
have this itinerary I just want to tell
you know like I'm in town if and if I
have time like I'll come see you and
then but also I'm sorry to Auntie that's
that's vacation with Hitler like that's
insane I agree a little bit but I I do
understand
a little bit where he's coming from not
saying that I agree with him and also if
it were me and like Zach had some we
were on a family trip and like he wants
to go visit with someone for a few hours
in the day I'd be like oh my God amazing
go oh same and I imagine I'm thinking
like if these were my in-laws like my
in-laws would invite them over to sleep
over like yeah but people are different
and it's like we didn't and it also if
they're like paying for you it's like we
didn't pay for your trip to go see your
aunt you know this isn't like your
family why are you so controlling why
are you so crazy no honestly I I'm on
your side here like I think you can see
your aunt like I get families mixes but
like but no it's not mixing it's gonna
be an outing and she's gonna go alone so
it's not making the boyfriend's not
gonna come that's not rude he doesn't
need to come take him and also like he's
already being a freak like so yeah don't
invite like don't make him come it's not
mixing but
I think you need to find like the right
it's you have to it's a delicate line
but also it's like
it's just it is weird no but the thing
is the boyfriend probably hasn't told
his parents about it yet and it's
entirely possible the parents were like
oh man of course go see your aunt like
they understand family before he's like
reacting on behalf he thinks they're
gonna react yeah right keep her locked
up but you know what she said
she's her boyfriend no there's boyfriend
girlfriend okay but like you know
families do have to start mixing when
you get married and stuff like that and
like you know what like you should set
stop with the mixing no but I'm saying
like you should set if you let them
steamroll over you on this like you're
setting a precedent like go see your
[__] Aunt yeah but that's not about
mixing you being independent which is
and we'll probably meet this family if
they get married agree but like if they
don't get married like why did we meet
your aunt I don't need them to meet the
ant okay no I don't need them
you're desperate for them to mix no I'm
not I'm just saying they will if you get
engaged like your family's of course and
when you get engaged but if I'm the
boyfriend I'm saying no but what you do
in your relationship sets precedent for
for your life which is why I think you
need to assert your Independence but not
the mixing of the ant I didn't say mix
you said mix so many times in this
conversation I literally didn't say it I
didn't say that these problems
I didn't [__] say that okay you did
you said mixing can be weird but it has
to I didn't I did say that I did say
that why do we need to talk about mixing
we might get married
but mixing is not what this is about
it's about you asserting your
Independence on a family trip okay
whatever you say toxic future
mother-in-law okay that is true but I
don't I don't even know like
if Harry's girlfriend wanted to go you
guys are going to the Florida yeah but
I'm the type that's like go goodbye yeah
please get out of my space like like
absence makes our girlfriend I miss you
yeah and then I can't wait for you to
come back like I think like time spent
like that's always good when someone has
like oh I like this to do this today and
I'm gonna go what if she wanted to take
Harry
[__] crazy
it depends it depends a million things
like are we it's just a really short
vacation we don't have a lot of time
where are we on vacation where how
really how far does the ant live is it
what is she missing out on is this
somewhere that's like a remote place
that it's like oh my God it's so crazy
that I'm down the street from this and
or it's like somewhere you could go
anytime we're going down the shore it's
circumcision it's circumstantial really
but ultimately like he can go wherever
the [__] he wants no and ultimately like
he's gonna mix families
with that girl one day but not today
um go see your aunt you go see your aunt
for sure if your boyfriend doesn't want
to come like uh who cares literally who
cares you want to see your aunt yeah
you weren't like I really want my aunt
to meet my boyfriend you have free will
girly don't forget that was that only
two no those three that was three robust
ring right this one yeah hope we were
able to solve some of your you know
titillating prompts
Harry was on a trip with his girlfriend
and you were down the street
you bet you get your ass over there you
don't go to Claudia's town without
seeing antiquoia it's true see now now
you see it so if it's an anti-coya type
of anti right how important is his
auntie because there are degrees of
antiques and I think it's important for
you to let us know what degree of anti
this is first degree I think it's also
important for you to send us an update
if we've read your prompt on air
recently today or in past weeks
deertoesters gmail.com just write an
update in the subject line so I can have
an easy time finding it thank you to
everyone who wrote in thank you to
everyone who
made this 999th episode
so special so so great it took us 999
episodes to realize that Kylie and
Morgan Wallen need to be together
Kylie Wallen and that's why we do what
we do and we will never stop ever thank
you guys so much for listening to the
toast the millennial Morning Show where
we deliver the past five stories that
you need to know every Monday through
Friday on YouTube so if you're watching
this on YouTube please feel free to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so that
Spotify iTunes Stitch or public radio I
heart radiocast works all the places so
maybe listen to podcast finesse so
sleepy five star review about a
beautiful setting in what
[Music]
what challenge did we are hope you guys
have it in Korea pump day and we'll see
you tomorrow for arth
episode
goodbye love you bye